- Maligayang pagbabalik sa Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
Ang pangalan ko ay John Watrous, at
ako ang Technical Director para sa IBM Quantum Education.
Ito ang ikaapat na aralin ng serye at ito ang huling
aralin sa unang unit ng serye tungkol sa mga
pangunahing konsepto ng quantum information.
Sa ngayon, napag-usapan na natin
kung paano gumagana ang quantum information para sa isa at maraming sistema, at tiningnan na natin ang
quantum circuit model,
at naobserbahan na natin ang ilang
pangunahing limitasyon ng quantum information.
Sa proseso, nakilala natin ang ilang mahalagang konsepto sa matematika
kabilang ang tensor products at inner products, at magpapatuloy tayo
na gamitin ang mga konseptong iyon at magpapakilala tayo ng ilang bago
habang kailangan natin ang mga ito.
Sa araling ito, magtutuon tayo sa tatlong pangunahing mahahalagang halimbawa: quantum teleportation, superdense coding at ang CHSH game,
na tinatawag ding CHSH inequality at hindi palaging inilalarawan bilang isang laro.
Hindi ito mga basta-bastang
halimbawa na para lamang ilarawan kung paano gumagana ang quantum information, tunay itong mga pangunahing
bahagi ng pundasyon
ng quantum information at
lumilitaw ang mga ito sa iba't ibang at kung minsan ay hindi inaasahang sitwasyon sa loob ng quantum information
at computation.
Ang entanglement ay may mahalagang papel sa lahat ng tatlong
halimbawang ito, at sa katunayan, ang entanglement ang nagpapaandar sa kanila
at nagpapaganda ng mga ito. Kaya, ang araling ito ay, sa ilang paraan, magiging unang pagkakataon natin na
makita ang entanglement sa aksyon
at magsimulang tuklasin kung ano ang nagpapaganda ng entanglement.
Ang pangkalahatang balangkas ng
aralin ay napakasimple, isa-isa tayong
dadaan sa tatlong halimbawang binanggit ko kanina,
quantum teleportation,
superdense coding, at ang CHSH game.
Tatalakayin natin kung ano ang mga bagay na ito at kung ano ang nagpapaganda ng mga ito at dadaan tayo sa mga pagsusuri na nagpapaliwanag kung paano eksakto ang pagguganap ng mga ito
sa antas ng matematika.
Bago tayo pumunta sa una
sa tatlong halimbawa, na siyang quantum teleportation, angkop munang
ipakilala ang mga tauhan,
sina Alice at Bob, kung hindi ka
pamilyar sa kanila.
Sina Alice at Bob ay mga pangalan
na ibinibigay sa mga hypothetical na entidad o ahente sa mga sistema, protocol, laro,
at talagang sa anumang uri ng interaksyon na gusto mong isaalang-alang na kinabibilangan ng pagpapalitan ng impormasyon.
Lumabas sila una sa
konteksto ng cryptography noong 1970s, ngunit ang
kaugaliang gamitin ang mga pangalang ito sa ganitong paraan ay naging napaka-karaniwan na
sa mas malawak na konteksto mula noon. Ang ideya ay ang mga ito
ay napaka-karaniwang pangalan, kahit sa ilang bahagi ng mundo, at nagsisimula sila sa mga titik na A at B,
at maginhawa rin
ang pagtukoy sa kanila gamit ang mga panghalip na siya at siya para sa kaiklian.
Karaniwan nating inaakala na si Alice at Bob ay nasa iba't ibang lugar at mayroon silang iba't ibang
layunin at iba't ibang gawi
depende sa kung ano ang pinag-uusapan natin.
Halimbawa, kung nag-uusap tayo
tungkol sa komunikasyon, ibig sabihin, ang pagpapadala ng impormasyon, maaari nating pagpasyahan
na si Alice ang nagpapadala
at si Bob ang tumatanggap
ng anumang impormasyon na ipinapadala.
Kung minsan ay nagtutulungan sina Alice at Bob,
karaniwan ito, ngunit kung minsan ay nagtatagisan sila o maaaring magkaibang layunin ang kanilang mga layunin na maaari o maaaring hindi
ay magkatugma sa isa't isa, ngunit
lahat ng ito ay kailangang linawin sa sitwasyong nasa kamay natin.
Siyempre, kumakatawan sila sa mga abstraksiyon at hindi kinakailangan na aktwal na mga tao.
Maaari rin tayong magpakilala ng
karagdagang mga tauhan tulad nina Charlie at
Diane o iba't ibang pangalan na kumakatawan sa iba't ibang
persona tulad ni Eve
para sa isang maton o si Mallory para sa isang nagpapakita ng masamang pag-uugali
depende sa sitwasyon.
Sa anumang kaso, makikita natin sina Alice at Bob sa lahat ng tatlong
halimbawang tatalakayin natin sa araling ito at paminsan-minsan
sa natitirang bahagi ng serye. Gagawa rin ako ng ilang
komento tungkol sa entanglement bago lumipat sa tatlong halimbawa.
Sa ikalawang aralin, natuklasan natin ang halimbawang ito ng isang entangled state ng dalawang qubit.
Isa ito sa apat na bell states, at maaari mong sabihin na
ang partikular na state na ito ay kumakatawan sa arketipong halimbawa
ng isang entangled quantum state.
Natuklasan din natin ang
halimbawang ito ng isang probabilistic state ng dalawang bits.
Ito ay kahalintulad ng
entangled state sa ilang paraan, ngunit hindi ito entangled,
ang entanglement ay natatanging
quantum na kababalaghan,
sa pamamagitan ng kahulugan.
Mayroong tumpak na kahulugang matematikal kung ano ang entanglement at karaniwang sinasabi ng kahulugang iyon na ang entanglement
ay isang non-classical quantum correlation.
Ngunit hindi iyon masyadong
nakatutulong sa intuitive na antas, ito ay isang kahulugan ng entanglement sa mga tuntunin ng kung ano ang hindi entanglement,
at malamang ay dahil doon
na medyo mahirap ipaliwanag kung ano ang entanglement at kung ano ang nagpapaganda nito
sa intuitive na mga termino.
Kapag sinubukan ng mga tao na
ipaliwanag kung ano ang entanglement sa intuitive na mga termino, madalas kang makarinig ng mga paliwanag na talagang hindi
nagpapakilala sa dalawang estado na ito
sa makabuluhang paraan. Maaari mong marinig ang ideya
na kung susukat ka sa isa sa dalawang entangled qubit,
ang estado ng isa
ay parang kaagad na naaapektuhan o ang estado ng dalawang qubit ay hindi mapapaliwanag nang hiwalay
o ang dalawang qubit
ay parang nagtatago ng alaala ng isa't isa o kahit na
sila ay emosyonal na nakakonekta sa ilang paraan.
Ngunit bakit hindi totoo ang mga katangiang iyon para sa estado na ito?
Ang dalawang bits na ito ay malapit na magkaugnay, ang bawat isa ay may perpektong
alaala ng isa pa sa literal na kahulugan, ngunit
hindi ito isang entangled state.
Well, isang paraan upang ipaliwanag kung ano ang
nagpapaganda ng entanglement at kung paano naiiba ang estado na ito
mula sa estado na iyon ay ang ipaliwanag kung ano ang
magagawa natin sa entanglement
o kung ano ang maaaring mangyari
dahil sa entanglement na lampas sa mga desisyon na ginagawa natin tungkol sa kung paano kinakatawan ang ating
kaalaman gamit ang mga vector.
Lahat ng tatlong halimbawa
na tatalakayin natin sa araling ito ay may ganitong katangian sapagkat inilalarawan nila
ang mga bagay na magagawa natin sa entanglement na hindi
natin magagawa sa estado na ito
o sa anumang classically correlated state.
Sa katunayan, napaka-karaniwan sa pag-aaral ng quantum information at computation na tinitingnan natin ang entanglement bilang isang resource
kung saan maaaring magawa ang iba't ibang
gawain.
At kapag ginawa natin iyon, tinitingnan natin ang estado na ito bilang kumakatawan sa
isang unit ng entanglement.
Tinutukoy natin ang unit ng
entanglement na ito bilang isang e-bit, ang e ay nakatayo para sa
entangled o entanglement.
Totoo na ito ay dalawang qubit, ngunit bilang dami ng
entanglement, ito ay isang e-bit.
Maaari mo ring tingnan ang isang pares
ng mga ordinaryong classical bits sa correlated
probabilistic state mula kanina bilang isang resource na
isang bit ng shared randomness.
Maaaring maging napaka-kapaki-pakinabang sa
cryptography ang pagbabahagi ng random bit sa isang tao basta
wala nang ibang nakakaalam kung ano ang bit na iyon para magamit ito bilang private key
o bilang bahagi ng private key, halimbawa, para sa encryption.
Ngunit sa araling ito, ang ating pokus ay sa entangled state na ito at
sa mga bagay na magagawa natin dito.
At para linawin ang terminolohiya, kapag sinabi nating ibinabahagi nina Alice at Bob ang isang e-bit, ang ibig sabihin nito ay
mayroon si Alice ng isang qubit na pinangalanang A,
mayroon si Bob ng isang qubit na pinangalanang B, at magkasama ang pares na A, B
ay nasa Phi plus state.
Hindi mahalaga kung anong mga pangalan
ang pipiliin natin para sa dalawang qubit, siyempre, maaari tayong
pumili ng iba't ibang pangalan, ngunit sa buong araling ito,
mananatili tayo sa mga pangalang ito
para sa kalinawan. Ang unang halimbawa ng aralin
ay quantum teleportation,
na mula rito ay tatawaging
teleportation lamang para sa kaiklian.
Ang teleportation ay isang protocol na nagbibigay-daan sa nagpapadala na
magpadala ng quantum information sa tatanggap gamit lamang ang entanglement
at classical communication para
maisakatuparan ang paglilipat na iyon.
Wala itong kaugnayan sa tipikal na interpretasyon
ng salitang teleportation sa science fiction, na
ang bagay ay nawawala
sa isang lugar at lumilitaw sa iba.
Ang quantum teleportation ay isang pangalan lamang na inilaan upang magbigay ng imahe o metapora, kung baga.
Ang nate-teleport ay
quantum information at hindi bagay, at nangyayari ito
sa pamamagitan ng pagpapadala ng classical information
kasama ang entanglement.
Upang maunawaan kung paano eksakto
gumagana ang teleportation, kapaki-pakinabang na simulan sa
pagtatakda ng eksena, kung baga.
Ang gagawin natin ay isipin ang isang sitwasyon na kinabibilangan nina Alice at Bob at
ang sitwasyong iyon ay ganito,
mayroon si Alice ng isang qubit na pinangalanang Q na
nais niyang ipadala kay Bob, ibig sabihin nais niya na si Bob ang mayroon nito sa kanyang mga kamay
ng isang qubit na nasa eksaktong
parehong estado na nasa Q habang nagsisimula ang protocol.
Sa madaling salita, pinag-uusapan natin ang pangunahing problema ng
pagpapadala ng impormasyon o komunikasyon.
Mayroon tayong nagpapadala na si Alice
at isang tatanggap na si Bob at nais ni Alice na magpadala
ng quantum information sa anyo ng isang qubit kay Bob.
Ngunit mayroon isang hadlang, na si Alice ay hindi
kayang pisikal na ipadala ang Q kay Bob, ang magagawa lamang niya ay magpadala ng classical information kay Bob.
Mayroon din sina Alice at Bob ng
karagdagang resource, na ibinabahagi nila ang isang e-bit.
Iyon ang sitwasyon, madaling isipin ang mga sitwasyon kung saan ang hadlang na
hindi kayang ipadala ni Alice ang Q
kay Bob ay isang makatwirang abstraksiyon.
Kung sina Alice at Bob ay nasa
magkaibang kontinente halimbawa, o kung hindi alam ni Alice ang
eksaktong lokasyon ni Bob, ang pisikal na pagpapadala ng qubit
ay malamang na medyo mahirap.
Ngunit ang classical communication
siyempre ay hindi lamang posible kundi napakamura rin
sa ilalim ng mga pagkakataong iyon.
Ngayon, maaaring magtanong ang isa kung posible ba para sina Alice at Bob na maisakatuparan ang gawaing ito nang hindi kailangan ang shared e-bit.
Sa madaling salita, mayroon bang
paraan upang mapadala ang isang qubit gamit ang classical
communication lamang?
Ang sagot ay hindi, hindi posible ang magpadala ng quantum information gamit ang classical communication lamang, at hindi masyadong mahirap patunayan iyon
gamit ang ilang pangunahing
quantum information theory, na makikita natin sa
ikatlong unit ng serye.
Sa ngayon, isang intuitive
na paraan upang pag-isipan ito ay ang pag-isip tungkol sa no-cloning theorem.
Isipin na mayroon ng paraan
upang mapadala ang quantum information gamit ang classical communication lamang,
ngunit ang classical communication
ay madaling makopya at mai-broadcast, kaya nangangahulugang
ang classical communication
ay maaaring mai-broadcast sa dalawang
tatanggap, sina Bob at Charlie, halimbawa.
Kung parehong natanggap nila ang
parehong classical information mula kay Alice, sila ba ay parehong magtatapos na may Q?
Ipapahiwatig nito na nag-clone tayo ng Q, ngunit alam nating imposible iyon.
Bilang isang bahagi, obserbahan natin
na tiyak na posible na ilarawan ang
quantum state vectors gamit ang classical information.
Bawat quantum state vector
na makikita mo sa serye ay inilalarawan sa iyo
gamit ang classical information na ipinasa sa anumang
device na pinapanood mo.
Sa pangkalahatan, maaari nating isipin ang
paglalarawan ng anumang estado na nasa Q gamit ang classical bits
marahil sa ilang katumpakan,
ngunit hindi iyon quantum communication, ito ay paglalarawan lamang ng
quantum states bilang mga vector, at babalikan natin ang
pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng mga ito
sa ilang sandali.
Pero bumabalik sa sitwasyon at nagtatrabaho sa ilalim ng
asumpsyon na ibinabahagi nina Alice at Bob ang isang e-bit, makikita natin na sina Alice at Bob
ay mayroon ng lahat ng kailangan nila
upang maisakatuparan ang gawain, at iyon ang ginagawa ng quantum
teleportation protocol, partikular gamit ang dalawang bits
ng classical communication.
Bago tayo pumasok sa
mga detalyeng ito, hayaan mo akong gumawa ng ilang mabilis na
komento upang masiguro na malinaw ang mga asumpsyon.
Una, inaasahan natin
dito na ang estado ng Q ay hindi alam nina Alice at
Bob, kaya sa partikular,
hindi kayang ipadala ni Alice kay Bob ang
paglalarawan ng estado Q dahil hindi niya ito alam sa pangkalahatan.
Kailangan din nating isaalang-alang ang posibilidad na ang Q ay may kaugnayan sa ibang mga sistema, kabilang ang posibilidad
na ito ay entangled
sa ibang mga sistema at ang
pagpapadala ng qubit na ito kay Bob ay dapat mapanatili ang mga ugnayan na iyon.
Sa wakas, binanggit ko
ang no-cloning theorem nang pinag-uusapan ko ang
pagsubok na mag-communicate ng qubit nang classically, ngunit
mayroon pang isa pang koneksyon dito
sa no-cloning theorem, na kung
tatanggap si Bob ng pagpapadala ng qubit Q na ito mula kay Alice,
dapat wala na itong nasa kanya
dahil hindi maaaring i-clone ang Q, at iyon ay isang bagay na dapat tandaan
habang isinasaalang-alang natin ang teleportation protocol.
Ang teleportation
protocol ay maaaring ilarawan sa medyo simpleng at direktang paraan gamit ang quantum circuit diagram na makikita mo dito.
Ito ay bahagyang estilisado sa
pagpapalabas nito ng paghihiwalay sa pagitan ng bahagi ni Alice at ng bahagi ni Bob, ngunit kung hindi man, ito ay isang
quantum circuit diagram lamang,
lahat ng nasa itaas ng tuldok na linya ay kumakatawan sa mga aksyon ni Alice at lahat ng nasa ibaba
ay kumakatawan sa mga aksyon ni Bob.
Ang oras ay gumagalaw mula kaliwa hanggang kanan tulad ng dati, at nakikita natin na nagsisimula tayo
sa dalawang qubit na ito na nasa Phi plus state,
kaya ito ang e-bit
na sinimulan nina Alice at Bob.
Maaari tayong maglagay ng mga label sa mga qubit upang malinaw kung alin ang
alin, kaya ito ang qubit A, at ito ang qubit
B na bumubuo ng e-bit,
at ito ang qubit Q na
nais ni Alice na ipadala kay Bob.
Dito ay inaakala natin na
ang estado ng qubit Q na ito ay Psi, ngunit kalaunan ay isasaalang-alang natin ang posibilidad
na ang Q ay entangled
sa ibang sistema. At ang sinasabi ng diagram dahil isinulat natin ang psi dito sa ibaba,
ay ang circuit
na ito ay epektibong nagpapadala ng anumang estado psi na mayroon tayo
dito sa bahagi ni Alice pababa dito sa bahagi ni Bob,
ang tanging komunikasyon
na tumawid sa
linya sa pagitan nina Alice at Bob ay ang dalawang classical
bits na kinakatawan ng mga double line dito.
Paliitan natin ng kaunti ang diagram na ito upang magkaroon tayo ng kaunting mas maraming espasyo at tuklasin natin ang
circuit nang mas malapit.
Inilalarawan ko na
ang mga paunang kondisyon, ngunit upang muling ibuod, hawak ni Alice ang qubit A
at hawak ni Bob ang qubit B,
kung saan ang A at B magkasama
ay nasa Phi plus state, kaya iyon ang ibig sabihin ng pagbabahagi ng e-bit.
Mayroon din si Alice ng qubit Q na nais niyang ipadala kay Bob, at isinasaalang-alang natin ang kaso na ang Q ay nasa ilang arbitrary na quantum state na Psi.
Ngayon, wala tayong alam
tungkol sa kung paano nagkaroon nina Alice at Bob ng e-bit na ito.
Posible na
mayroon na sila nito nang matagal, marahil ginawa nila ito ilang panahon na ang nakalipas nang sila ay magkasama sa parehong lugar
at inilaan nila ito
para sa okasyong ito, ngunit ang mga detalyeng iyon ay hindi na-aaplika dito.
Ang mga hakbang na susunod, na kumakatawan sa
teleportation protocol mismo ay ganito, at para maging malinaw,
ito ang mga hakbang na
inilalarawan ng diagram at isusulat lamang natin ang mga ito
sa mga salita upang malinaw ang
ipinahahayag ng diagram.
Si Alice ay unang gumaganap ng
controlled-NOT operation kung saan ang qubit Q na
nais niyang ipadala kay Bob ay ang control at ang
qubit A ay ang target.
Ang susunod na hakbang ay ang pagsasagawa niya ng
Hadamard operation sa Q, at pagkatapos ay sinusukat niya
ang dalawang qubit na hawak niya,
ang A at Q ayon sa
standard basis measurements at hayaan nating ang lowercase a ay ang resulta ng pagsukat ng qubit A,
at hayaan nating ang lowercase b ay ang resulta ng pagsukat ng qubit Q.
Pagkatapos ay ipinadadala ni Alice ang
dalawang classical bits na iyon kay Bob at ito ang tanging komunikasyon na kasangkot sa protocol na ito at ipinapakita ito sa diagram
sa pamamagitan ng katotohanang ang dalawang
bits na ito ay tumatawid sa tuldok na linya sa pagitan nina Alice at Bob,
na maaari mong isipin bilang kumakatawan sa anumang
distansya na naghihiwalay sa kanila.
Pagkatapos matanggap ni Bob ang mga bits
na a at b, ginagawa niya ang dalawang bagay.
Una, kung ang a ay katumbas ng isa, gumaganap siya ng X
operation o sa madaling salita, isang NOT gate sa kanyang qubit B,
at kung hindi ay katumbas ng zero ang a, hindi niya gagawin iyon.
At katulad nito,
kung ang b ay katumbas ng isa, gumaganap si Bob ng Z operation
o isang Z-gate o isang phase flip
pati na rin sa qubit b at tulad ng
dati, kung ang b ay katumbas ng zero, hindi niya gagawin iyon.
Lahat ng ito ay ipinapakita sa figure kung saan mayroon tayong mga controlled-X
at controlled-Z gates kung saan ang mga kontrol ay
ang dalawang classical bits.
Hindi mo kailangang isipin ang mga gate na ito bilang mga control gate
kung ayaw mo, ito ay isang maginhawang paraan lamang
upang ipahayag ang gusto natin
sa anyo ng circuit diagram. Ang punto ay ang pag-aplay ni Bob ng
X-gate sa qubit b kung ang a ay katumbas ng isa at
pagkatapos ay ang pag-aplay niya ng Z-gate
sa qubit b kung ang B ay katumbas ng isa.
At para sa kaginhawahan mamaya ay maaari tayong isulat nang eksakto
ang pinagsama-samang operasyon na ginagawa ni Bob sa kanyang qubit b,
depende sa classical
bits na ipinapadala ni Alice.
Kaya iyon ang teleportation protocol, medyo simple ito talaga, ang
katotohanang gumagana ito talaga ay isa pang bagay
at bagaman ang pagsusuri
ay hindi masyadong kumplikado,
hindi ka dapat magparamdam na may napalampas ka kung hindi mo agad makita kung bakit gumagana ito.
Kaya naman kailangan nating
dumaan sa isang pagsusuri at iyon ang gagawin natin susunod.
Upang masuri ang teleportation protocol, dadaan tayo sa ito nang hakbang-hakbang upang makita kung ano ang mga estado
ng tatlong qubit sa iba't ibang punto sa oras.
Una ay isasaalang-alang natin
ang kaso na ang tuktok na qubit ay nasa estado na AlphaZero plus beta one, kung saan ang alpha at beta
ay anumang complex na numero
na nagsasanhi ng vector na ito
na maging isang unit vector.
Ito ang qubit Q na
sinusubukan ni Alice na ipadala, ngunit hindi talaga natin pinapakialam kung paano ito tinatawag sa ngayon.
Kalaunan, tititingnan natin
ang sitwasyon kung saan ang qubit na ito ay
entangled sa ibang sistema, ngunit ito ay isang magandang simula upang panatilihing simple ang mga bagay
at makita kung paano gumagana ang pagsusuri
nang mas malinaw.
Kung isasaalang-alang natin ang estado ng
tatlong qubit nang magkasama dito sa simula, makikita natin
na ang estado na ito ay may anyo na makikita mo dito.
Ang unang dalawang qubit ay
nasa Phi plus state, ang ikatlong qubit ay ang pinakamataas
ayon sa kumbensyon
para sa pag-order ng mga qubit na
inilalarawan ko sa nakaraang aralin, at kaya kukunin natin ang tensor product upang makuha ang estado ng
tatlong qubit nang magkasama.
Maaari nating i-expand ang expression na ito
sa pamamagitan ng unang pagpapalit ng kahulugan ng Phi plus state at pagkatapos ay ang pag-compute ng tensor product
at makuha natin ang estado
na makikita mo dito.
Hindi palagi ang pinakamabuting
estratehiya, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ang ganap na i-expand
ang isang vector tulad nito, karaniwan itong magandang ideya na hintayin hanggang
mayroon kang magandang dahilan para gawin ito.
Ngunit dito mayroon tayong dahilan, na gusto nating
i-compute ang aksyon ng controlled NOT gate na ito at sa pamamagitan ng pagsulat ng estado sa anyo na ito,
madali nating magagawa iyon.
At sa partikular, ito ay
ang estado ng tatlong qubit pagkatapos na ma-apply ang controlled NOT gate.
Ang ikatlong qubit ay ang control qubit dahil iyon ang
nasa itaas ayon sa ating kumbensyon, at ang ikalawang qubit,
na siyang nasa gitna,
ay ang target, kaya pinoprotektahan lamang natin ang mga cats nang naaangkop, kung ang ikatlong bit ay
zero, walang nangyayari,
at kung ang ikatlong bit ay isa,
i-flip natin ang ikalawang bit.
Pagkatapos ay isinasagawa natin ang Hadamard
gate sa ikatlong qubit, maaari nating isulat ang resultang
vector tulad ng makikita mo
dito sa pamamagitan ng pagpapalit ng
plus at minus state para sa zero at one state.
At kung gusto nating magkaroon ng sapat na
espasyo upang i-expand ito, kailangan nating paliitan
ito nang kaunti at ngayon, sa pamamagitan ng pagpapalit ng
plus at minus states
sa kanilang mga kahulugan,
pagdadala ng square root ng dalawa sa denominator, makuha natin ang estado na makikita mo dito.
At sa pamamagitan ng pag-expand nito, makuha natin ang estado na makikita mo dito.
Kaya, iyon ang estado ng tatlong qubit pagkatapos na isakatuparan ni Alice ang kanyang dalawang operasyon.
Pagkatapos ay sinusukat ni Alice
at kung gusto nating suriin ang mga sukat, ang ginagawa natin ay i-isolate ang mga standard basis vectors
para sa mga sistema na sinusukat
tulad ng napag-usapan natin sa ikalawang aralin, at kung gagawin natin iyon sa partikular na kasong ito, ito ang makukuha natin.
At kung titingnan mo ang
expression na iyon sa isang sandali, maaari itong magmukha ng bahagyang kakaiba dahil ngayon ay tila ang unang qubit,
na siyang pinakamababang qubit
ay parang nakasalalay sa alpha at beta, kahit na
sa puntong ito ay wala pang komunikasyon na nagtawid sa tuldok na linya,
ngunit iyon ay ilusyon lamang. Tandaan na ang mga scalar ay
bumabaloy nang malaya sa pamamagitan ng mga tensor products, kaya wala talagang kahulugan
na ang alpha at beta
ay nauugnay sa unang qubit.
Ang talagang ginawa lamang natin
dito ay gumamit ng mga panaklong ayon sa
multilinearity ng mga tensor products.
Sa anumang paraan, iyon ang anyo na kailangan nating makita kung ano ang ginagawa ng pagsukat, at maaari nating makita ang isang
kawili-wiling bagay agad
at iyon ay ang mga probabilidad ng apat na posibleng resulta ng pagsukat ay palaging pantay-pantay.
Ang probabilidad na masukat ang bawat
pares ng mga resulta ng pagsukat ay isang-kapat, kaya, sa partikular,
walang anumang dependensya
sa alpha at beta.
Maaari nating makita iyon sa bawat kaso sa pamamagitan ng pag-compute ng Euclidean norm squared ng
anumang vector na naka-tensor sa standard basis
vector na na-isolate natin,
at sa bawat kaso mayroon tayong isang-kapat na nakukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-square ng isang-kalahati na beses ng absolute value squared ng alpha
kasama ang absolute value
squared ng beta, na isa, at kaya makakakuha tayo ng isang-kapat sa bawat kaso.
Napakahalaga sa katunayan
na ang mga probabilidad ng iba't ibang mga resulta ay hindi nakasalalay sa anumang paraan sa qubit na
nais ipadala ni Alice.
Hindi maaaring mangyari na ang isang arbitrary na estado ay papasok dito sa itaas at lalabas doon sa ibaba at gayon pa man ay inihayag ng pagsukat ang
impormasyon tungkol sa estado na iyon.
Kung gusto mong makakuha ng impormasyon tungkol sa isang arbitrary na quantum state, kailangan mong guluhin
ang estado na iyon sa pangkalahatan.
Narito ang isang talahanayan na naglalarawan hindi lamang ng mga probabilidad
ng iba't ibang mga resulta, kundi pati na rin ang estado ng
tatlong qubit nang magkasama
na conditioned sa bawat posibleng
resulta ng pagsukat.
Nakukuha natin ito sa pamamagitan ng pag-normalize ng mga vector na naka-tensor sa iba't ibang
standard basis states, ngunit madali ito sa kasong ito,
aalisin lamang natin ang factor na isang-kalahati upang makakuha ng isang unit vector.
Kaya, agad pagkatapos ng pagsukat ni Alice ay mayroon si Alice ng dalawang uniform
random bits at iyon na iyon.
Sa partikular, wala na siya ng
orihinal na estado at wala siyang
anumang impormasyon tungkol dito, mayroon lamang siyang random bits.
Ang estado ni Bob ngayon ay
nakasalalay sa alpha at beta pati na rin sa mga resulta ng pagsukat.
Kung pansamantalang iisipin natin
na hindi pa naipadala ni Alice ang mga resulta ng pagsukat
para hindi alam ni Bob kung ano ang mga resulta ng pagsukat,
hindi siya makakakuha
ng anumang impormasyon tungkol sa alpha at beta
mula sa pagsukat ng kanyang qubit.
Ang apat na posibilidad
na mayroon tayo dito ay sapat na nascrabled upang masiguro na walang impormasyon
tungkol sa alpha at beta
ang maaaring makuha
sa pamamagitan ng pagsukat. Dapat itong maging totoo sa intuitive na antas dahil kung hindi ay magkakaroon tayo ng
faster than light communication.
Tiyak na hindi kayang
magpadala ng impormasyon si Alice kay Bob nang hindi nagpapadala ng anumang bagay, ngunit siyempre ay nagpapadala si Alice ng mga resulta ng pagsukat
kay Bob, kaya i-expand natin ang talahanayan upang makita kung ano ang mangyayari kapag
ginanap ni Bob ang kanyang mga operasyon.
Sa kolumnang ito, mayroon tayong iba't ibang mga operasyon na epektibong ginagawa ni Bob para sa bawat isa sa mga posibleng
resulta ng mga pagsukat
tulad ng naobserbahan natin bago,
at kung isa-isang dadaan tayo at ialapat natin ang operasyong
iyon sa qubit ni Bob, na siyang una, B,
makikita natin na nakukuha natin ang parehong
resulta sa lahat ng apat na kaso at ang resulta na iyon ay ang orihinal na estado.
Kaya, ang orihinal na estado ng qubit Q ay matagumpay na na-teleport sa B.
Kung nais ni Bob na palitan ang pangalan ng kanyang qubit at tawaging Q ito sa puntong ito, mayroon siyang kalayaan na gawin iyon, ngunit ang punto ay ngayon
hawak niya ang orihinal na estado
na mayroon si Alice at siyempre sa pamamagitan ng pangangailangan, wala na ito kay Alice.
Pansinin din na ang e-bit
ay epektibong nasunog sa prosesong ito,
ang teleportation ay may gastos
at ang gastos ay isang e-bit at dalawang classical bits ng komunikasyon, at kapag tapos na ang protocol,
wala na ang e-bit.
Napatunayan na natin ngayon na
gumagana nang tama ang teleportation protocol sa ilalim ng asumpsyon na ang tuktok na qubit ay nasa isang quantum state
ng anyo na alpha beses cat
zero kasama ang beta beses cat one.
Ngunit ano ang mangyayari kung ang
tuktok na qubit ay entangled sa ibang sistema tulad ng
isa sa ating karagdagang qubit
tulad ng mayroon tayo dito sa screen? Maaaring nais nating gamitin ang teleportation
sa ganitong mga pagkakataon.
Marahil si Alice at Bob ay aktwal na
nagpaplano na magsagawa ng teleportation nang 100 beses upang si Alice ay makapagpadala
ng isang 100 qubit quantum register
kay Bob, isang qubit sa isang pagkakataon.
O marahil ang karagdagang
mga qubit ay wala sa pag-aari ni Alice
at ibang tao ang nagtataglay nito, marahil hindi man alam ni Alice
na naroroon sila.
Ang tanong ay, gumagana pa rin ba ang
teleportation kahit na ang qubit na nite-teleport ay entangled sa ibang sistema?
Dito, ang estado ng qubit Q kasama ang karagdagang
sistema na isinasaalang-alang natin ay ipinahayag tulad ng makikita mo dito sa itaas
kung saan ang gamma zero at
gamma one ay mga unit vector na kumakatawan sa mga quantum states
ng karagdagang sistemang ito.
Lagi nating maisusulat ang isang arbitrary na estado ng combined system sa ganitong paraan.
Hindi natin talagang kailangan
ang alpha at beta dito, ngunit kung isasama natin sila,
maaari nating kunin ang gamma zero at gamma one bilang mga unit vector
at gagawing mas malinaw ang
koneksyon sa mas simpleng kaso na isinaalang-alang na natin.
Maaari tayong dumaan sa
katulad na pagsusuri sa isa na naraanan na natin, ngunit kung saan itinataguyod din natin
ang karagdagang sistemang ito.
Ito ay medyo mas magulo dahil mayroon tayong karagdagang sistema, ngunit
ang ideya ay eksaktong pareho, narito ang isang maikling buod.
Ito ang paunang estado, narito ang estado pagkatapos
ng controlled NOT gate,
at narito ang estado pagkatapos
ng Hadamard operation.
Kung i-expand natin ang mga bagay na ito
, maaari nating ipahayag ang estado na iyon tulad ng makikita mo dito,
iyon ang estado kaagad
bago ang mga pagsukat ni Alice, at kung dadaan tayo sa
mga posibilidad tulad ng dati
at isinasaalang-alang natin kung ano ang
mangyayari kapag inilapat ni Bob ang anumang operasyong dapat niyang ilapat,
makikita natin na sa katunayan
ang tamang estado ay lalabas at gumagana ang protocol tulad ng inaasahan.
Sa talahanayang ito sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ginagamit natin ang titik na R upang
sumangguni sa karagdagang sistemang ito, at maaari mong makita na gumagamit tayo ng medyo simpleng trick,
na ang pagpapasya na mas gusto natin, kahit pansamantala, ang pag-order
ng mga sistema bilang B, R, A, Q
dahil iyon ay mas maginhawa para sa pagsusulat ng mga estado dito.
Ayon sa diagram, ang mga sistema ay dapat
na inorder bilang B, A, Q, R,
ngunit hanggang malinaw natin ito, maaari tayong pumili ng ibang
pag-order na mas maginhawa.
Sa madaling salita, lahat ng nangyayari sa pagsusuring ito ay
kapareho ng nangyari sa mas simpleng pagsusuri,
ngunit nagtataglay tayo ng
mga karagdagang vector na ito, ang gamma zero at gamma one
na karaniwang pumupunta kasama ang paglalakbay.
Mayroon palaging gamma zero
kapag mayroong factor ng alpha at gamma one kapag
mayroong factor ng beta at sa katapusan ng araw,
lahat ay gumagana nang tama.
Hindi ito nakakagulat talaga, mayroon tayong isang pisikal na proseso na kumikilos tulad ng identity
operation sa isang qubit
sa isang arbitrary na quantum state, at mayroon lamang isang
paraan na maaaring mangyari iyon at iyon ay ang operasyon
ay ang identity operation.
Iyon ay medyo mas madaling ipaliwanag gamit ang pangkalahatang formulation
ng quantum information, ngunit ang punto ay sa pamamagitan ng linearity,
hindi talaga nating kailangan na dumaan sa karagdagang pagsusuring ito.
Kapag alam na natin na
ang teleportation ay gumagana nang tama para sa isang qubit na mag-isa, maaari nating tapusin na mayroon lamang isang posibleng bagay
na maaaring ilarawan kung ano ang ginagawa ng protocol, at iyon ay ang pagpapatupad nito
ng identity operation kung saan ang isang qubit ay pumapasok dito
at lalabas dito, epektibong kumikilos bilang isang perpekto
at walang ingay na quantum channel.
Ilang mabilis na komento lamang
tungkol sa teleportation bago lumipat sa
ikalawang halimbawa ng aralin, na siyang superdense coding.
Una, sa tingin ko mahalaga na linawin na ang teleportation ay hindi isang application ng quantum information, ito ay isang protocol
at partikular na ito ay isang
protocol para sa pagsasagawa ng quantum communication.
Upang ang teleportation
tulad ng inilarawan ko ito ay maging kapaki-pakinabang, kailangang may dahilan para sa pagsasagawa ng quantum communication.
Pangalawa, makatutuwirang gumawa ng hypothesis na ang teleportation ay maaaring, isang
araw, maging isang karaniwang paraan
upang ma-communicate ang quantum information, at partikular isang proseso na kilala bilang entanglement distillation
ay posibleng magamit
bilang isang paraan upang ma-communicate ang mga qubit nang maaasahan. Kung alam nina Alice at Bob na magko-communicate sila ng quantum information o mayroon silang pangangailangan na mag-communicate
ng quantum information, kung gayon ang prosesong ito ng entanglement distillation
ay maaaring gamitin upang ma-convert ang mas malaking bilang ng mga maingay na e-bit
sa mas maliit na bilang
ng mataas na kalidad na mga e-bit na maaaring gamitin para sa walang ingay o malapit na walang ingay na teleportation.
Ang ideya ay ang proseso
ng entanglement distillation ay hindi masyadong deliкаdо sa ilang paraan, maaari nating tanggapin ang mga pagkawala at
kung hindi ito gumana,
maaari nating subukan muli ito, samantalang ang aktwal na mga qubit na
gusto nating i-communicate ay maaaring ituring na mas mahalaga.
Siyempre, lahat ng ito ay haka-haka, ngunit ang punto ay hindi mahirap gumawa ng hypothesis ng mga sitwasyon
kung saan ang teleportation
ay maaaring maging isang napaka-praktikal
na paraan upang ma-communicate ang mga qubit.
At ang huling punto
tungkol sa teleportation ay ang ideya sa likod ng teleportation at kung paano gumagana ito
ay napaka-pundamental
sa quantum information at computation, ang teleportation ay talagang isang cornerstone ng quantum information
theory at mga variation
sa ideya ay madalas ding lumabas,
isa lamang itong halimbawa, may mga panukala para sa
pagpapatupad ng iba't ibang quantum gate
gamit ang teleportation, ngunit
kung saan pinipili ang iba't ibang paunang estado at mga pagsukat upang ang resulta
ay ang pag-apply ng piniling operasyon
sa halip na ang pag-communicate.
Ang susunod na halimbawa ay superdense coding.
Tulad ng quantum teleportation,
ang superdense coding ay isang protocol at ang nagagawa nito ay kumplementaryo sa teleportation.
Samantalang ang teleportation ay nagbibigay-daan sa
isang qubit na mapadala gamit ang isang e-bit at dalawa
classical bits ng komunikasyon,
ang superdense coding ay nagbibigay-daan sa
dalawang classical bits na mapadala gamit ang
isang e-bit at isang qubit ng quantum communication.
Kaya, sa madaling salita, nagbibigay-daan ang superdense coding sa pagpapadala
ng classical information at ang dahilan kung bakit ito ay
tinatawag na superdense coding
ay dahil nagbibigay-daan ito sa dalawang
classical bits ng komunikasyon na maisakay sa isang qubit,
ngunit kailangan nating sunugin ang
isang e-bit upang maisakatuparan ito.
Narito ang isang mas tumpak
na paliwanag ng setup.
Muli, mayroon tayong sina Alice at Bob, kung saan si Alice ang nagpapadala
at si Bob ang tatanggap, at sa pagkakataong ito mayroon si Alice ng dalawang classical bits
na nais niyang ipadala kay Bob.
Kayang magpadala ni Alice kay Bob ng isang qubit at ibinabahagi nina Alice at Bob ang
isang e-bit na maaari nilang gamitin upang tulungan silang maisakatuparan ang kanilang gawain,
na para sa Bob na matanggap
ang dalawang classical bits.
Ngayon, sa ilang paraan ay maaaring magmukhang hindi gaanong kawili-wiling ang gawaing ito kaysa sa gawaing
nagagawa ng teleportation,
partikular kung tinitingnan natin
na ang pagpapadala ng mga qubit ay nangangailangan ng mas
mahirap o mas makapagtaglay kaysa sa pagpapadala ng mga classical bits,
na isang medyo makatwirang pananaw ngunit talagang kawili-wili na posible itong gawin.
Isang dahilan kung bakit kawili-wili ito
ay dahil talagang imposible na maisakatuparan
ang gawaing ito ng pagpapadala ng dalawang classical bits ng impormasyon
gamit ang isang qubit nang hindi
gumagamit ng e-bit.
Alam natin ito dahil sa isang sikat na theorem na kilala bilang Holevo's theorem.
Ang Holevo's theorem ay
mas pangkalahatan kaysa rito, at ang tumpak na pahayag
ng Holevo's theorem ay medyo teknikal at nangangailangan ng ilang paliwanag,
ngunit ang isang implikasyon nito
ay hindi ka makakapagpadala ng anumang bilang ng classical
bits ng komunikasyon gamit ang mas kaunting qubit ng
quantum communication lamang.
Kung nais mong maaasahang mapadala ang dalawang classical bits ng
impormasyon gamit ang mga qubit at wala kang
e-bit na magagamit,
kailangan mong magpadala ng dalawang qubit, kaya maaari na lamang nilang itago ang mga bits na nais mong ipadala.
Isa pang dahilan kung bakit kawili-wili ang superdense
coding ay dahil sa malapit
na kumplementaryong relasyon nito sa teleportation, at
babalikan natin ito
kalaunan. Narito ang isang quantum circuit na paglalarawan ng superdense coding protocol.
Para sa isang ito, hindi ko
ilalista ang lahat ng mga hakbang, ngunit sa halip ay mananatili tayo sa paglalarawang circuit diagram.
Tulad ng makikita mo, muli
mayroon tayong sina Alice at Bob, kung saan si Alice ay nasa itaas
at si Bob ay nasa ibaba.
Narito ang e-bit na
paunang ibinabahagi sa pagitan nina Alice at Bob, na
kahit paano ay naitatag bago pa tumatakbo ang protocol.
Mayroon si Alice ng dalawang classical bits, A at B, na makikita mo dito
at sa pamamagitan ng protocol na inilalarawan ng circuit,
ang dalawang classical bits na ito
ay magtatapos sa mga kamay ni Bob.
Isang qubit lamang
ang tumatawid sa linya sa pagitan nina Alice at Bob, at siyempre wala
itong anumang classical bits na ipinapadala,
ang pagpapadala ng
dalawang classical bits ay ang punto ng protocol.
Mapapansin mo rin na mayroon itong
eksaktong parehong mga component na ginagamit sa teleportation, mayroon tayong controlled NOT
gate, Hadamard gate,
at isang Z at isang X-gate
na kinokontrol ng mga classical bits.
Naiayos sila nang iba gayunpaman, kaya't magpatuloy tayo sa
pagsusuri upang makita kung paano gumagana ito.
Upang suriin kung paano gumagana ang superdense coding, simulan natin sa pamamagitan ng pagsulat
ng Bell basis, na napaka-sentral sa
pagsusuri.
Ang gagawin natin ay
unang titingnan ang epekto ng mga aksyon ni Alice
sa Phi plus state, at makikita natin na binabago ni Alice ito
Phi plus state sa isa
sa apat na Bell states depende sa mga bits
na nais niyang ipadala.
Kaya, isulat natin ang isang talahanayan upang masubaybayan
natin kung ano ang nangyayari.
Una, kung ang A at B ay parehong zero, walang nailapat na Z-gate o
X-gate, kaya ang mga aksyon ni Alice ay hindi gumagawa ng anumang bagay,
ibig sabihin na ang Phi
plus ay napo-map sa Phi plus.
Maaari rin nating ipahayag iyon bilang isang equation tulad ng makikita mo dito,
walang nangyayari sa qubit ni Alice at walang nangyayari sa qubit ni Bob
at ang paggawa ng wala ay kinakatawan
ng identity matrix.
Ngayon, ano ang mangyayari kung ang A ay katumbas ng zero at ang B ay katumbas ng isa?
Well, dahil ang B ay katumbas ng isa, ina-apply natin ang Z-gate at
hindi natin ina-apply ang X-gate dahil ang A ay katumbas ng zero
at makikita natin na ang pangkalahatang epekto ay ang pag-perform ni Alice ng Z-gate.
Si Alice ay nasa kanan
dahil nasa itaas siya, bagaman hindi ito
makakaapekto sa kasong ito, ang epekto ay
ang Phi plus state ay
napo-map sa Phi minus, na maaari mong matukoy
mula sa mga expression na ito kung naaalala mo kung paano gumagana ang Z-gate.
Kaya, maaari nating idagdag ito sa ating talahanayan, may dalawa pang kaso na dapat suriin, kung ang A ay katumbas ng isa
at ang B ay katumbas ng zero,
kung gayon gumaganap si Alice ng
X-gate na nagko-convert ng Phi plus sa Chi plus, at kung ang A ay katumbas ng isa
at ang B ay katumbas ng isa,
kung gayon gumaganap si Alice ng Z, pagkatapos
X at makukuha natin ang Chi minus.
Kaya, sinasabi sa atin ng ating talahanayan kung ano ang mangyayari sa apat na posibleng kaso at iyon ay epektibong pinipili ni Alice kung alin
sa apat na Bell states ang
nais niyang ibahagi kay Bob, at mayroon siyang kalayaan na pumili sa pamamagitan ng pagkilos sa kanyang qubit lamang
at iyon ay isang medyo kawili-wiling
aspeto ng entanglement.
Pagkatapos ay ipinadadala ni Alice ang kanyang qubit
kay Bob, sa puntong ito, hawak ni Bob ang isa sa apat na Bell states at kailangan lamang niyang
malaman kung alin ito
upang mabawi ang mga bits.
At maaari nating tiyakin na
ang isang controlled NOT gate na sinusundan ng isang Hadamard gate
tulad ng mayroon tayo sa diagram ay gumagawa ng tamang bagay.
Hindi ko dadaanan ang mga ito nang detalye, ngunit kung pipiliin mong gawin iyon, mahahanap mo na ang epekto ay
tulad ng makikita mo dito sa talahanayan.
Isang paraan upang suriin iyon
ay ang simpleng mag-compute. Bilang kahalili, maaari nating makilala na talagang naraanan na natin ito sa kabaligtaran
sa nakaraang aralin. Sa nakaraang aralin ay mayroon tayong Hadamard gate muna at pagkatapos ay ang controlled NOT gate
at nakita natin na ang circuit na iyon
ay nagma-map ng mga standard basis state sa mga Bell states na may nakakaistorbong
minus sign sa isa sa mga kaso.
Kapag binaliktad natin ang pagkakasunod-sunod ng mga gate at isinasaalang-alang natin ang katotohanang
ang parehong dalawang gate na ito ay kanilang sariling mga inverse,
ang makukuha natin ay ang inverse,
kaya ang mayroon tayo sa
kasong ito ay ang aksyon ay pumupunta sa kabaligtarang direksyon
at ang minus sign ay maaaring pumili kung aling
gilid ang nais niyang mapunta,
ngunit kung hindi man, nasa tama itong lugar, at sa puntong ito ay
agarang ipinapakita ng pagsukat ang tamang mga halaga,
ang minus sign dito ay hindi kami nag-aalala dahil ang isa ay lumalabas na may
probabilidad na isa sa kasong ito, at iyon lang ang mayroon sa pagsusuri.
Sa madaling salita, pinipili ni Alice ang isang Bell state at nalalaman ni Bob kung alin ito.
Ilang maikling komento lamang
tungkol sa superdense coding bago tayo lumipat; una, dapat nating kilalanin na ang superdense coding
ay malamang na hindi
magiging kapaki-pakinabang o praktikal sa anumang paraan bilang isang paraan upang
mapadala ang classical information.
Ang classical communication
ay napakamura at ang pisikal na pagpapadala ng mga qubit ay mapaghamong sabihin nang hindi masyadong maging maliwanag,
at hanggang ganoon ang kaso, hindi natin inaasahan na may
anumang praktikal na kalamangan na maidudulot ng superdense coding.
Ngunit ang katotohanang hindi malamang na ito ay magiging praktikal ay hindi nangangahulugang ang superdense
coding ay hindi kawili-wili.
Ito ay napaka-kawili-wili sa katunayan, para sa isa, ang pangunahing ideya ay
tunay na napakapundamental,
at kapag tinutukoy ko ang pangunahing ideya, ang ibig ko sabihin ay ang ideya na kung ibinabahagi ni Alice ang isang Bell state kay Bob,
kung gayon maaari siyang pumili na baguhin ang estado sa anumang ibang Bell state na
pipiliin niya nang mag-isa, hindi niya kailangan ang tulong ni Bob upang gawin iyon.
Ito ay isang tiyak na halimbawa
na nauukol sa mga Bell states, ngunit mayroon pang mas pangkalahatang pangunahing ideya na nauukol sa kalayaan ng isang manlalaro
na baguhin ang isang entangled state na ibinabahagi sa ibang manlalaro, at ang pag-unawa kung eksakto ano ang kalayaang iyon
ay isang mahalagang hakbang sa pag-unawa ng quantum information at eksakto kung paano natin malarawan ang kalayaang iyon sa simpleng
at eleganteng mga termino ay makikita sa
ikatlong unit ng serye.
Ang superdense coding din
ay nagbibigay ng kongkretong halimbawa ng kung ano ang magagawa mo sa entanglement, na ang pagbibigay-daan sa dalawang classical
bits na mapadala
sa pamamagitan ng pagpapadala ng isang qubit. Tulad ng nabanggit ko na, ito ay provably hindi posible ayon sa Holevo's theorem nang walang entanglement.
Maaari rin nating isaalang-alang ang teleportation at superdense coding nang magkasama, at makikita natin na nagtatatag sila ng katumbasan
sa pagitan ng isang qubit ng quantum communication at dalawang bits ng classical communication.
Hanggang handang
gumastos ng isang e-bit, maaari kang epektibong
mag-convert ng isa sa isa pa.
Nagbibigay-daan ang teleportation sa
komunikasyon ng isang qubit gamit ang dalawang classical bits ng komunikasyon at pumupunta ang superdense coding sa kabila
at nagbibigay-daan sa dalawang classical
bits ng komunikasyon gamit ang isang qubit ng quantum communication.
Nang hindi ginagastos ang e-bit, gayunpaman, hindi mo maco-convert
ang alinman sa isa pa, ang entanglement ang
nagpapaging-posible nito.
Ang ikatlo at huling halimbawa
na sasaklawin natin sa araling ito ay hindi isang protocol kundi isang
laro na kilala bilang CHSH game.
Kapag nagusap tayo ng isang laro sa kontekstong ito, hindi tayo nagtatalkabo tungkol sa isang bagay na inilaan na laruin para sa kasiyahan o palakasan,
kundi isang matematikal na abstraksiyon sa diwa ng game theory halimbawa.
Ang mga matematikal na abstraksiyon ng mga laro ay napaka-karaniwang pinag-aralan sa
economics at computer science, halimbawa, at mayroon
medyo maraming halaga
na matatagpuan sa abstraksiyon, kaya ang mga laro ay hindi lahat ay kasiyahan
sa mga laro pala,
bagaman ito ay masaya ang pag-iisip tungkol sa kanila.
Sa partikular na kasong ito, ang mayroon tayo ay karaniwang
isang thought experiment na maaaring ilarawan sa isang
medyo intuitive na paraan bilang isang laro.
Ang mga titik na CHSH ay tumutukoy sa mga may-akda, sina John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony, at Richard Holt ng isang papel noong 1969
kung saan ang halimbawa
ay unang inilarawan. Hindi nila ito inilarawan
bilang isang laro, sa katunayan, at napaka-karaniwan
na tumukoy sa halimbawang ito
hindi bilang CHSH game, kundi
bilang CHSH inequality.
Para sa isang computer scientist tulad ko, gayunpaman, ito ay napaka-natural
na ilarawan ito bilang isang laro.
Iminungkahi ko na
ang mga matematikal na abstraksiyon ng mga laro ay parehong mahalaga at kapaki-pakinabang at maraming iba't ibang
kategorya ng mga laro
na maaaring isaalang-alang. Ang CHSH game ay isang
halimbawa ng isang klase ng mga laro na tinatawag na non-local games.
Narito ang pangkalahatang setup
para sa isang non-local game.
Mayroon tayong dalawang manlalaro, sina Alice at Bob, na nagtutulungan bilang isang koponan, kaya nagtatagumpay sila nang magkasama
o natatalong magkasama.
Nangangahulugan ito na wala silang
insentibo na kumilos nang pabor sa sarili, kaya ito ay karaniwang kabaligtarang dulo sa zero sum games,
na purong mapagkumpitensya, dito ang laro ay purong kooperatibo.
Mayroon pa sa ikatlong entidad na tinatawag na referee.
Ang referee ay hindi isang manlalaro sa laro, kundi ang referee
ay nagpapatakbo ng laro, at sa katunayan, maaari mong isipin ang pagtukoy
ng isang partikular na instance
ng isang non-local game at ang pagtukoy ng isang
referee bilang katumbas.
Mayroon isang kritikal na mahalagang hadlang na inilalagay sa sina Alice at Bob, na kapag nagsimula na ang laro, ipinagbabawal silang makipag-communicate sa isa't isa.
Maaari silang sumang-ayon nang maaga sa
anumang estratehiya na pipiliin nila, ngunit walang komunikasyon
na pinapayagan sa pagitan nila sa panahon ng laro mismo.
Kung gusto mo, maaari mong isipin
ang laro na nagaganap sa isang secure na pasilidad ng ilang uri na parang ang referee ay gumaganap
ng papel ng isang detective
at sina Alice at Bob ay mga suspek na nasa iba't ibang
silid sa isang police station, ngunit isa pang paraan ng
pag-iisip tungkol sa setup
ay sina Alice at Bob ay
pinaghiwalay ng napakalawak na distansya at ang komunikasyon ay ipinagbabawal dahil ang bilis ng liwanag
ay hindi nagbibigay-daan para sa komunikasyon
na mangyari nang sapat na mabilis. Kung susubukan ni Alice na magpadala ng
mensahe kay Bob halimbawa, matatapos na ang laro bago
pa matanggap ito ni Bob.
Ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho ng isang non-local game
ay una, tinatanong ng referee ang parehong
sina Alice at Bob ng isang tanong.
Ang tanong ni Alice ay nilalagyan ng label na X at ang tanong ni Bob ay nilalagyan ng label na Y.
Sa pangkalahatan, maaari mong isipin ang X at Y bilang mga classical states
mula sa anumang classical states na gusto mo at sa
partikular na kaso ng CHSH game,
ang X at Y ay mga bits.
Pagkatapos ay dapat magbigay ng mga sagot sina Alice at Bob, ang sagot ni Alice ay nilalagyan ng label na A,
at ang sagot ni Bob ay nilalagyan ng label na B,
at muli, ang mga sagot na ito ay maaaring tingnan bilang mga classical states sa pangkalahatan at tulad ng mga tanong, sila
ay magiging mga bits sa CHSH game.
Sa puntong ito,
gumagawa ng desisyon ang referee, ang mga pagtatagumpay o pagkatalo nina Alice at Bob ay nakasalalay sa kung ang pares ng mga sagot A, B
ay itinuring na tama para sa
pares ng mga tanong X, Y na tinanong ng referee, at magsasabi pa ako ng kaunti
tungkol dito sa ilang sandali.
Una, tumingin tayo nang mas malapit sa referee upang maunawaan kung ano ang
potensyal na mapaghamong para sina Alice at Bob sa isang non-local game.
At ang nagpapaging-potensyal na mapaghamong
sa isang non-local game ay ang referee ay maaaring gumamit ng randomness upang pumili ng mga tanong X at Y.
Nangangahulugan iyon na sina Alice
at Bob ay may kawalan ng katiyakan, hindi nila alam nang maaga kung anong tanong ang itatanong sa kanila, at marahil mas mahalaga,
hindi nila alam kung anong tanong
ang natanggap ng isa pa at ang kawalan ng katiyakang iyon
kasama ang katotohanang hindi sila maaaring mag-communicate
ang nagtatambay ng hamon.
Kaya, katulad ito sa sitwasyon kung saan ikinuwestyon ng isang detective
ang dalawang suspek sa iba't ibang silid, kung
hindi alam ng mga suspek
kung anong mga tanong ang itinanong sa isa pa, mas mahirap kung sila ay nagkasala na panatilihing tuwid ang kanilang kwento.
Ngayon, binanggit ko ilang sandali na ang nakalipas na ang referee ay gumagawa ng determinasyon
na si Alice at Bob ay sumasagot nang
tama o mali
depende sa mga tanong
na itinanong sa kanila.
Inaakala na ang
determinasyong ito ay ginagawa ayon sa ilang fixed
na panuntunan at maaari kang mag-isip ng anumang panuntunan na gusto mo, ngunit anuman ang mayroon,
inaakala na alam nina Alice
at Bob ang panuntunan, kaya hindi bababa mayroon silang isang pagkakataon
na sagutin nang tama.
Titingnan natin ang
panuntunan para sa CHSH game sa ilang sandali, ngunit maaari tayo
isaalang-alang ang ibang panuntunan at magkaroon tayo ng ibang
halimbawa ng isang non-local game.
Ang ilang non-local games ay kawili-wili at sa katunayan ang ilan ay talagang kahanga-hanga at misteryoso hanggang sa kasalukuyan at
ang ilan ay hindi masyadong kawili-wili,
iyon ay ang kalikasan lamang ng
non-local game model.
Sa anumang paraan, ito ang dalawang iba't ibang bagay na kailangan upang ilarawan ang isang referee; kung paano eksakto pinipili ang mga tanong
at kung aling mga pares ng sagot ay tama para sa bawat posibleng pares ng tanong.
Kung mayroon tayong paglalarawan
ng dalawang bagay na iyon, mayroon tayong paglalarawan para sa referee at epektibong inilalarawan iyon
ng isang instance ng isang non-local game.
Ngayon ay titingnan natin ang
CHSH game nang partikular.
Ang paraan ng pagpapakahulugan ng laro o, katumbas, kung paano tinutukoy ang referee ay ganito;
una, tulad ng nabanggit ko na, ang mga tanong at sagot ay lahat ng mga bits, kaya nagpapadala ang referee ng bit X
kay Alice at isang bit Y kay Bob,
at sumasagot silang parehong may isang bit. Sumasagot si Alice gamit ang A
at sumasagot si Bob gamit ang B.
Ang paraan ng pagpili ng referee
kung aling mga tanong ang itatanong ay simple, pinipili niya
ang mga ito nang randomly at pantay-pantay,
kaya, ang pares ng mga tanong X, Y ay may pantay na pagkakataon na maging sinuman
sa apat na posibilidad, zero, zero, zero, isa,
isa, zero, at isa, isa.
Sa wakas, ang panuntunan na
nagtatakda kung aling mga sagot ang mananalo at aling mga sagot ang matatalo ay
ang pares ng mga sagot A, B ay tama para sa pares ng mga tanong X, Y
kung at kung lamang ang exclusive or ng A at B ay katumbas ng logical and ng X at Y.
Maaaring maging mas madaling tanggapin iyon kung ipinapahayag natin ang mga kondisyong iyon
sa anyo ng isang talahanayan tulad ng makikita mo dito.
Sa unang kolumna, mayroon tayong apat na posibleng pares ng tanong, at sa ikalawang kolumna mayroon tayong mga kondisyon sa A at B
na kinakailangan para sa
tagumpay nina Alice at Bob.
Sa unang tatlong kaso,
ang and ng A at Y ay zero, kaya ang exclusive or ay dapat katumbas ng zero
upang sila ay manalo,
at iyon ay katulad ng pagsasabi na ang A at B ay dapat katumbas dahil ang A at B ay mga bits, at sa ikaapat na kaso,
ang and ng X at Y ay katumbas
ng isa at kaya ang exclusive or ng A at B ay dapat katumbas ng isa upang manalo sina Alice at Bob
at iyon ay katulad ng pagsasabi
na ang A at B ay dapat magkaiba.
Kaya, iyon ang CHSH game, at ngayon ay maaari tayong mag-isip tungkol sa
iba't ibang posibleng estratehiya para sina Alice at Bob at kung gaano kahusay nila magagawa sa larong ito.
Magsimula tayo sa pag-iisip tungkol sa
mga deterministic na estratehiya kung saan ang sagot ni Alice A ay isang
function ng tanong X na natanggap niya, at
katulad nito, ang sagot ni Bob B
ay isang function ng
tanong Y na natanggap niya.
At sa katunayan, walang
deterministic na estratehiya ang maaaring manalo nang palagi.
Isang paraan upang mangatuwiran nito ay
simpleng isa-isahin ang lahat ng posibleng
deterministic na estratehiya at tiyakin na ang bawat isa sa kanila ay natatalong
para sa kahit isa sa apat na
posibleng pares ng tanong.
Sina Alice at Bob, ang bawat isa ay mayroon
apat na posibleng function na mapipili, nakita natin ang
apat na function na iyon sa unang aralin, kaya mayroon 16 na posibilidad
na susuriin sa kabuuan.
Isa pang paraan upang makita iyon ay ang
pag-iisip tungkol sa mga equation dito sa screen, nagtatalo tayo
tungkol sa mga deterministic na estratehiya
kung saan ang A at B ay mga function
ng X at Y ayon sa pagkakataon.
Kaya halimbawa, ang A ng zero
ay kumakatawan sa sagot ni Alice kapag ang kanyang tanong X ay katumbas ng zero at ang a ng isa ay kumakatawan sa sagot ni Alice
kapag ang kanyang tanong X ay katumbas ng isa.
Ito ang apat na equation
na dapat maging totoo upang matugunan ang mga kondisyon ng tagumpay sa bawat isa sa apat na kaso.
Halimbawa, kung ang X ay katumbas ng
zero at ang Y ay katumbas ng zero, kung gayon ang exclusive or ng A
at B ay dapat katumbas ng zero,
samantalang sa kaso na ang X ay katumbas ng isa at ang Y ay katumbas ng isa, ang
exclusive or ng A at B ay dapat katumbas ng isa.
Isang paraan na maaari nating makita na
walang paraan upang mapili ang mga function A at B upang
ang lahat ng mga equation na ito ay maging totoo, ay ang simpleng kunin ang exclusive
or ng lahat ng mga equation.
Ang exclusive or ng anumang
binary na halaga na may sarili nito ay katumbas ng zero, at kaya sumusunod na ang exclusive or
ng mga kaliwang bahagi
ay katumbas ng zero, iyon ay
dahil mayroon tayong dalawang instance ng a zero, dalawang instance ng a one,
dalawang instance ng B zero
at dalawang instance ng B one.
Kaya, ang pag-xor ng lahat ng magkasama
ay nagbibigay sa atin ng huling sagot na zero, ngunit kung kunin natin ang exclusive or ng mga kanang bahagi ng mga equation,
makukuha natin ang isa at hindi zero. Kaya ang apat na equation
ay hindi maaaring lahat ay maging totoo, hindi bababa ay dapat mali ang isa sa kanila
at hahantong iyon sa
pagkatalo para sina Alice at Bob sa hindi bababa sa isa sa apat na kaso.
At kaya sumusunod dahil pinipili ng referee ang mga tanong
nang pantay-pantay na ang probabilidad para manalo sina Alice at Bob
gamit ang isang deterministic na estratehiya
ay pinakamataas na tatlong-kapat o 75%.
Ang katotohanang sina Alice at Bob ay maaaring manalo nang may probabilidad na tatlong-kapat ay medyo madaling makita
sa katunayan, kung parehong sumasagot ng zero sina Alice at Bob sa lahat ng oras, halimbawa,
sila ay magiging tama nang tatlo
sa apat na beses.
Kaya hindi kayang maging mas mahusay sina Alice at Bob kaysa sa panalong 75% ng oras gamit ang
isang deterministic na estratehiya.
Ngunit paano ang isang probabilistic na estratehiya?
Well, sa katunayan, ang paggamit ng
isang probabilistic na estratehiya ay hindi makakatulong sa kanila nang kahit kaunti, iyon ay dahil ang bawat
probabilistic na estratehiya
ay maaari ring tingnan
bilang isang random na pagpili ng isang deterministic na estratehiya tulad ng mga probabilistic
na operasyon ay maaaring tingnan
bilang mga random na pagpili ng
mga deterministic na operasyon, tulad ng nakita natin sa unang aralin.
Ang average ay hindi kailanman
mas malaki kaysa sa maximum, kaya sumusunod na ang isang
probabilistic na estratehiya ay hindi nag-aalok ng anumang kalamangan
sa mga tuntunin ng panalong
kaysa sa isang deterministic na estratehiya. Kasama rin nito ang posibilidad na ang mga random
na pagpili nina Alice at Bob ay correlated.
Kaya, ang buod ay ang panalong may probabilidad na tatlong-kapat ay ang pinakamahusay na magagawa nina Alice
at Bob gamit ang anumang classical na estratehiya,
maging ito ay deterministic
o probabilistic.
Ang natural na tanong na itatanong sa puntong ito ay kung kayang maging mas mahusay nina Alice at Bob gamit ang isang quantum na estratehiya,
at sa partikular
kung ibinabahagi nila ang isang entangled quantum state na maaari nilang naitatag
bago pa maglaro ang laro, makakatulong ba iyon sa kanila?
Ang sagot ay oo, maaari, at iyon ang punto ng halimbawa at iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ito ay napaka-kawili-wili.
Kaya tingnan natin kung paano eksakto
kayang maging mas mahusay sina Alice at Bob sa larong ito gamit ang entanglement.
Ang unang bagay na kailangan nating gawin ay tukuyin ang isang quantum state vector Chi
theta para sa bawat anggulo theta, tulad ng makikita mo dito sa screen.
Kaya, ang Chi theta ay katumbas ng
cosine theta beses cat zero kasama ang sine theta beses cat
one, at dito sa pamamagitan ng paraan,
iniisip natin ang
mga anggulo sa mga tuntunin ng radians.
Kaya halimbawa, narito ang vector na nakukuha natin kapag ang theta ay katumbas ng pi over
four, na 45 degrees.
Ang cosine ng pi over four
at ang sine ng pi over four ay parehong katumbas ng isa sa ibabaw
ng square root ng dalawa, kaya ito ay isa lamang pang
pangalan para sa plus state.
Narito pa isang halimbawa kapag ang theta ay katumbas ng tatlong beses ng pi over eight, at kung sakaling hindi mo
alam ang sine
at cosine ng tatlong beses ng pi over eight nang maaga,
narito ang isang talahanayan ng mga sine at cosine na talagang
kakailanganin natin
sa buong halimbawang ito
at kinabibilangan ng mga kailangan natin para sa partikular na vector na ito.
Ngayon, kung nais nating kunin ang inner product sa pagitan ng alinman sa dalawang vector na ito
para sa mga anggulo, alpha at beta halimbawa, ito ay
madali itong gawin.
Mayroon lamang tayong real number
na mga entry sa mga vector na ito kaya walang mga complex
conjugate na dapat alalahanin at nakukuha natin ang produkto ng mga cosine
kasama ang produkto ng mga sine, at maaari tayong gumamit ng isa sa
tinatawag na angle addition formulas
upang pasimplehin iyon, ito ang
cosine ng pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng mga anggulo at
dahil ang cosine function
ay simetrikal sa paligid ng zero,
hindi talaga mahalaga kung sa anong pagkakasunod-sunod natin sila kunin.
Kung hindi mo pa naaalala ang mga uri ng
trigonometric identities na ito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, hindi ka nag-iisa, ngunit hindi mo na kailangang alalahanin ang mga ito,
maaari mo lamang itong hanapin. Ang isang ito ay may kahulugan
gayunpaman kapag naisip mo ang geometric na interpretasyon
ng inner product
sa pagitan ng mga real unit vector bilang cosine ng anggulo sa pagitan nila.
Kung i-compute natin ang inner
product ng tensor product ng alinman sa dalawang vector na ito
kasama ang Phi plus state, makukuha natin ang katulad na expression
maliban na mayroong squared
of two sa denominator.
Ito ang unang pagkakataon
na lumabas ang Phi plus state sa konteksto
ng halimbawang ito sa pamamagitan ng paraan, at makikita natin kung bakit tayo interesado
sa partikular na inner product na ito sa ilang sandali, ngunit sa sandaling ito
ay ating obserbahan lamang na nakukuha natin ang parehong expression na mayroon tayo
para sa inner product na hinati
ng square root ng dalawa kaya maaari nating pasimplehin tulad ng dati.
Susunod, tutukuyin natin ang isang
unitary matrix, U theta, para sa bawat anggulo theta
tulad ng makikita mo dito,
hindi mahirap
tiyakin na ito ay tunay na isang unitary matrix.
Ang pangunahing bagay na kailangan nating
makilala ay ang vector si theta ay orthogonal sa
vector si theta kasama ang pi over two, at may kahulugan iyon
dahil kung irorotate natin ng pi over two, na 90 degrees, makukuha natin
ang isang orthogonal na vector.
Kung pagkatapos ay i-multiply natin ang U
theta sa U theta dagger, makukuha natin ang identity matrix.
Sa intuitive na pagsasalita,
ang ginagawa ng matrix na ito bilang isang operasyon ay ang
pag-map ng si theta sa cat zero at si theta kasama ang pi two sa cat one.
Sa puntong ito, mayroon na tayong
lahat ng kailangan natin upang ilarawan ang estratehiya nina Alice at Bob.
Una, tulad ng mayroon natin para sa teleportation at superdense coding, magsisimula sina Alice at Bob sa pamamagitan ng pagbabahagi ng isang e-bit.
Hawak ni Alice ang isang qubit A,
hawak ni Bob ang isang qubit B, at magkasama ang dalawang qubit
ay nasa Phi plus state.
Ang mga aksyon ni Alice ay ganito; tinitingnan niya ang bit X na
natanggap niya mula sa referee,
at kung ang X ay katumbas ng zero,
gumaganap siya ng U zero sa A, na siyang
parehong bagay tulad ng paggawa ng wala dahil ang U zero ay ang identity matrix,
ang effects ay katumbas ng isa sa kabilang panig, ina-apply niya ang U pi over four sa A.
Pagkatapos na ma-apply niya ang isa
sa dalawang operasyon, sinusukat niya ang A gamit ang
standard basis measurement at ipinapadala niya ang anumang resultang
makukuha niya sa referee.
Gumagawa si Bob ng katulad na bagay, ang kanyang qubit ay tinatawag na B siyempre, at natanggap niya ang Y mula sa
referee sa halip na X
ngunit ang pangunahing pagkakaiba ay
ang paggamit niya ng iba't ibang mga anggulo para sa kanyang unitary operations.
Kung ang Y ay katumbas ng zero, ina-apply niya
ang U pi over eight, at kung ang Y ay katumbas ng isa, ina-apply niya ang u negative pi over eight.
At makikita natin kung bakit ang mga pagpipiliang ito ng mga anggulo ay magagandang pagpipilian sa ilang sandali,
hindi ito malinaw talaga.
At narito ang isang circuit diagram
na nagpapahayag ng estratehiyang ito.
Si Bob ay nasa itaas at si Alice
ay nasa ibaba sa pagkakataong ito, narito ang e-bit na papasok
at ito ang mga unitary
gate na maaaring o maaaring hindi inilapat nina Alice at Bob
depende sa kung ano ang X at Y.
Para sa isang ito at sa isang ito, mayroon tayong mga gate na kinokontrol alinman ng bit X o ng bit Y
at para sa dalawang ito dito, mayroon tayong kung ano ang mukhang parang mga control gate maliban na ang bilog ay hindi pinuno.
At ang ibig sabihin nito ay
kung ang control bit ay nakatakda sa zero, kung gayon ang gate ay isinasagawa at kung ang control ay nakatakda sa
isa, kung gayon walang nangyayari.
Kaya, katulad lang ito ng
ordinaryong control gate maliban na ang mga papel ng zero at isa para sa control ay napalitan.
Kaya, epektibong, gumaganap si Bob
ng gate na ito dito kung ang Y ay katumbas ng zero, gumaganap siya ng gate na ito dito
kung ang Y ay katumbas ng isa, at katulad nito, gumaganap si Alice ng gate na ito dito
kung ang X ay katumbas ng zero, at ng gate na ito dito,
kung ang X ay katumbas ng isa.
Kaya, iyon ang estratehiya nina Alice at Bob at ngayon kailangan lamang nating
malaman kung gaano kahusay gumagana ito.
Para sa pagsusuri ng quantum na estratehiya na inilarawan ko, dalawang bagay lamang talaga ang kailangan natin sa puntong ito, una, ang
unitary matrix U Theta
ay tulad ng makikita mo dito, at
pangalawa, mayroon tayong formula na ito.
Hindi na natin talagang kailangan pa ang kahulugan ng vector si theta, ang dalawang equation na ito ay lahat ng kailangan natin.
May apat na kaso na dapat
isaalang-alang simula sa kaso isa, na ang X ay katumbas ng
zero at ang Y ay katumbas ng zero.
At kung titingnan natin muli ang estratehiya, mahahanap natin na sa
kasong ito gumaganap si Alice ng U zero sa kanyang qubit at gumaganap si Bob
ng U pi over eight sa kanyang qubit.
Tandaan, si Alice ay nasa
ibaba at si Bob ay nasa itaas, kaya ang estado na
nakukuha nila ay ganito ang hitsura.
At sa pamamagitan ng pag-expand nito
ayon sa kahulugan ng U theta, nakukuha natin itong
expression na makikita mo dito.
Hindi na natin kailangang i-expand
iyon pa dahil mayroon tayong ibang
formula upang tulungan tayo.
At kung ina-apply natin ang formula na iyon
para sa bawat isa sa apat na termino, ang makukuha natin ay ito.
Sa puntong ito ay parehong sumusukat sina Alice at Bob at narito ang isang talahanayan na
nagpapaliwanag ng distribusyon ng mga resulta.
Kinukuha natin ang absolute value
squared ng mga coefficient upang makuha ang mga probabilidad, na siyang mga
parisukat ng mga coefficient
dahil ang mga coefficient ay
lahat ng real numbers sa kasong ito.
Kung gagamitin natin ang
mga halaga ng sine at cosine mula sa kanina sa aralin
kasama ang ilang simetriya, maaari nating ipahayag ang mga probabilidad na ito
tulad ng mayroon tayo dito
sa huling kolumna.
Ngayon, ang talagang pinakaintereso natin
ay ang probabilidad na sila ay manalo, at tandaan na, sa kaso na ang X at Y ay parehong zero,
mananalo sila kung ang A at B ay katumbas at matatalo sila kung ang A at B ay hindi katumbas.
Kung i-compute natin ang mga probabilidad na iyon, mahahanap natin na ang probabilidad
na ang A at B ay katumbas ay ang kabuuan ng numerong ito at numerong ito,
na katumbas ng dalawa kasama ang
root two lahat sa ibabaw ng apat, na mga 85%.
Ang probabilidad na ang A at B ay hindi katumbas ay dalawa minus root two lahat sa ibabaw ng apat, na natural na isa minus ang dami
na kakalakalang kinalkula natin, kaya
mananalo sila nang may probabilidad na mga 85% sa kasong ito.
May tatlong pang kaso na dapat isaalang-alang, ngunit lahat sila ay napaka-katulad sa isang ito,
sa kaso na ang X ay katumbas ng
zero at ang Y ay katumbas ng isa, ina-apply ni Bob ang U negative pi over eight sa halip na U pi over eight,
ang mga halaga sa
mga formula ay nagbabago ng bahagya, ngunit natatapos tayo sa eksaktong
parehong mga probabilidad na mayroon tayo sa nakaraang kaso.
Kapag ang X ay katumbas ng zero at ang Y ay katumbas ng isa, mananalo pa rin sina Alice at Bob
kapag ang A at B ay katumbas at kaya mayroon tayong eksaktong parehong probabilidad ng tagumpay
tulad ng dati.
Sa ikatlong kaso, kapag ang X ay katumbas ng isa at ang Y ay katumbas ng zero, mayroon tayong katulad na sitwasyon, ang mga anggulo ay iba,
ngunit mayroon silang eksaktong
parehong relasyon sa
isa't isa, at sa katunayan, nakukuha natin ng eksaktong
parehong vector na nakuha natin sa nakaraang kaso.
Kaya ang mga probabilidad ay pareho at gayon din ang probabilidad ng tagumpay.
Ang huling kaso ay bahagyang
iba tulad ng inaasahan natin dahil ang kondisyon ng tagumpay
ay iba sa kasong ito.
Kapag ang X at Y ay parehong katumbas ng isa, mananalo sina Alice at Bob kapag
ang A at B ay magkaiba.
Ang pangunahing pamamaraan ay pareho, bagaman ang mga anggulo ay iba, sa pagkakataong ito, nakukuha natin ang vector na ito dito
at maaari mong tiyakin iyon sa pamamagitan ng pagdaan sa mga kinakailangang pagbabawas.
Ang mga probabilidad ay nagbabago sa wakas, at kung titingnan natin ang mga halagang kailangan natin, makikita natin na ang mga probabilidad ay epektibong
nagpalitan ng posisyon mula kanina, kaya sa pagkakataong ito ang probabilidad
na ang A ay hindi katumbas ng B, ang mas malaki sa dalawa,
ngunit iyon ay mabuti dahil sa kasong ito, mananalo sina Alice at Bob kapag
ang A at B ay hindi katumbas.
Kaya muli, mananalo sila nang may
probabilidad na humigit-kumulang 85%.
Dahil mananalo sila sa bawat
kaso nang may parehong probabilidad, na dalawa kasama ang root two
lahat sa ibabaw ng apat o mga 85%,
iyon ang probabilidad
na sila ay mananalo sa kabuuan.
Mas mahusay iyon kaysa sa anumang classical na estratehiya ang magagawa para sa larong ito, at iyon ang
nagpapaganda nito.
Ito pala ang
optimal na probabilidad ng tagumpay para sa anumang quantum na estratehiya, hindi ka
makapagpapabuti nang higit pa gamit ang anumang entangled state.
Ang katotohanang iyon ay kilala bilang Tsirelson inequality, pinangalan ito para kay Boris
Tsirelson na unang nagpatunay nito, at ayon sa aking kaalaman ay isa sa mga unang tao
na naglalarawan sa halimbawang ito bilang isang laro. Kung sakaling ang pagsusuri
na inilarawan natin ay mukhang medyo misteryoso,
posible itong isipin
nang geometrically, na maaaring makatulong
upang mas maunawaan ang pagpipili ng mga anggulo.
Partikular, kung gagamitin natin ang
formula na makikita mo dito, na madali nating mababatak
mula sa mga expression
na nahanap na natin para sa
mga inner product na kasangkot, maaari nating bilang kahalili
ipahayag ang mga probabilidad ng iba't ibang posibleng
mga resulta ng pagsukat
sa apat na kaso tulad ng sumusunod; una, kung ang X, Y ay katumbas ng zero, zero, kung gayon ito ang mga probabilidad
ng iba't ibang mga resulta ng pagsukat, at kailangan mong alinman ay bumalik o tumingin muli sa pagsusuri
na inilarawan natin upang tapusin iyon gamit ang ating formula.
Dito, maaari nating makita ang
iba't ibang state vector na iginuhit tulad ng dati, at ang color coding dito
ay ang asul ay kumakatawan
sa resulta na zero at ang pula
ay kumakatawan sa resulta na isa.
Maaari mong makita na ang anggulo
sa pagitan ng mga asul na vector at ang anggulo sa pagitan ng mga pulang
vector ay medyo maliit,
ito ay pi over eight sa parehong kaso, kaya ang cosine ay medyo malaki, at nangangahulugan iyon na ang probabilidad na ang dalawang resulta
ay katumbas ay medyo malaki.
Sa kaso na ang X, Y ay katumbas ng zero, isa, katulad ang sitwasyon, ang
mga anggulo sa pagitan ng mga vector na may parehong kulay ay maliit,
kaya ang probabilidad ng
mga katumbas na resulta ay muli, medyo malaki.
Ang ikatlong kaso ay katulad, at sa ikaapat na kaso
kapag ang X, Y ay katumbas ng isa, isa, may kawili-wiling nangyayari,
sa pagkakataong ito, dahil lang sa paraan,
ang mga vector na ito ay pinili, makikita natin na ang mga anggulo sa pagitan ng
mga vector na may parehong kulay
ay medyo malaki, at partikular ang mga anggulo ay tatlong beses
ng pi over eight sa parehong kaso.
Nangangahulugan ito na ang probabilidad
na ang mga resulta ng pagsukat ay katumbas ay medyo maliit, ngunit ito ang isang kaso
kung saan mananalo sina Alice at Bob
kapag ang kanilang mga sagot ay hindi nagkakasundo,
kaya iyon ang nais natin.
Muli, narito ang mga vector: kapag ang X, Y ay katumbas ng zero, zero,
kapag ang X, Y ay katumbas ng zero, isa,
kapag ang X, Y ay katumbas ng isa, zero,
at kapag ang X, Y ay katumbas ng isa, isa.
At marahil ang geometric
na larawang ito ay nakakatulong sa pagbuo ng ilang intuisyon
para sa kung paano gumagana ang estratehiyang ito
at kung bakit pinili ang iba't ibang mga anggulo sa paraang pinili ang mga ito.
Upang tapusin ang aralin, gagawa ako ng ilang maikling
komento tungkol sa CHSH game.
Una, tulad ng nabanggit ko na, ang halimbawang ito ay hindi palaging
inilarawan bilang isang laro.
Sa komunidad ng physics, halimbawa, mas karaniwan na
ang halimbawa ay inilalarawan nang simple bilang isang eksperimento sa halip na isang laro
at sina Alice at Bob ay
tinitingnan bilang mga detector sa halip na mga manlalaro.
Ang pangunahing ideya ng isang eksperimento tulad nito kung saan ang entanglement ay humahantong
sa mga resulta ng estadistika na hindi tugma sa
anumang classical na paglalarawan
o mas pangkalahatan ay anumang
teorya batay sa tinatawag na local hidden variables,
ay dahil kay John Bell, ang pinagmulan ng pangalan ng mga Bell states,
at kaya madalas na tinutukoy ng mga tao
ang mga eksperimentong ganito bilang mga Bell test.
Minsan ay tinutukoy rin ng mga tao ang Bell's theorem, na maaaring mabuo sa iba't ibang paraan, ngunit karaniwang sinasabi nito
na ang quantum mechanics
ay hindi katugma sa tinatawag na local hidden variable theories.
Ang CHSH game o inequality ay karaniwang isang napakaganda at malinis
na halimbawa ng isang Bell test,
at maaari mong isipin ang
halimbawang ito bilang isang patunay o isang demonstrasyon ng Bell's theorem.
Ang ikalawang komento ay ang CHSH game ay nag-aalok sa atin ng isang paraan upang eksperimental na subukan na ang teorya ng quantum information
ay isang tumpak na teorya. Maaari tayong talagang mag-set up ng mga eksperimento na nagpapatupad ng CHSH game,
kabilang ang uri ng
estratehiya batay sa entanglement na inilarawan ko kanina, at
tingnan kung gumagana ito, at gumagana ito.
Nagbibigay ito sa atin ng
mataas na antas ng kumpiyansa na ang entanglement ay tunay, at hindi tulad ng marahil
malabo o makatulang mga paraan
na sinusubukan nating gamitin upang
ipaliwanag ang entanglement, ang CHSH game o eksperimento
ay nagbibigay sa atin ng kongkreto
at nasusubok na paraan upang maobserbahan ang entanglement.
Kung iyon ay mukhang mahalaga,
iyon ay dahil ito ay mahalaga, at ang Nobel Prize sa physics
noong 2022 ay eksakto itong kinikilala.
Ang premyo ay iniaward kay
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, na siyang C sa CHSH, at Anton Zeilinger
para sa mga eksperimento sa mga entangled na photon na nagtatag ng paglabag
ng mga Bell inequality, o sa madaling salita, na
nagpakita na ang mga quantum na estratehiya
ng uri na inilarawan ko ay talagang gumagana at mas mahusay kaysa sa mga classical na estratehiya.
At kung interesado kang
matuto nang higit pa tungkol dito, hinihikayat kita na tingnan
ang video tungkol sa Bells Theorem ng aking kasamahan na si Olivia Lanes,
dito sa Qiskit YouTube channel.
At sa wakas, ang paksa ng
mga non-local games nang mas pangkalahatan ay tunay na kahanga-hanga, at ito ay
isang aktibong lugar ng pananaliksik
na nagbubuklod sa
physics, computer science, at purong matematika at marami pa ring
kawili-wiling mga tanong
tungkol sa mga non-local games na
nananatiling hindi nasasagot hanggang sa araw na ito.
At iyon ang katapusan ng ika-apat na aralin, pati na rin ang katapusan ng
unit one ng serye sa Basics of Quantum Information.
Ang unang aralin ay nagpaliwanag
kung paano gumagana ang quantum information para sa mga solong sistema na mag-isa, at ang ikalawang aralin ay nagpaliwanag kung paano gumagana ang quantum information
para sa maraming sistema,
na medyo natural na lumalabas mula sa kung paano ito gumagana para sa mga solong sistema.
Ang ikatlong aralin ay nagpakilala ng
quantum circuit model ng computation, at sa ikaapat na aralin, tiningnan natin ang tatlong mahalagang halimbawa
na naglalarawan ng mga bagay na magagawa natin sa entanglement.
Sa proseso, nakita natin ang ilang napakahalaga na mga konsepto sa matematika,
kabilang ang mga tensor products at inner products, at naobserbahan natin
ang ilang pangunahing limitasyon
ng quantum information.
Umaasa akong samahan mo ako sa
susunod na unit ng serye, na magiging tungkol sa mga quantum algorithm, kung saan magtutuon tayo sa tanong
ng kung anong mga computational na kalamangan
ang inaalok ng quantum information.
Paalam hanggang sa muli.